c'est le couple présidentiel
actuellement oui monsieur maquereau ou
d'un maquereau au maroc qui se balade
ils ont besoin de souffler un peu tu as
compris l'année qu'ils ont vu c'est vrai
et donc justement sur le génie l'eau qui
frotte le génie sort elie vous avez le
droit veut et d'écouté au génie est
président la république d'avoir des
problèmes rires c'est vrai que moi j'ai
pu vivre j'aimerais bien quand mes
parents m'ont toujours parlé de mon
arrière arrière grand mère j'aimerais
bien l'avoir adia non on peut pas faire
un choix j'ai dit je peux pas faire
revivre les morts choisi un autre j'ai
un autre un autre veut il débat écouter
j'aimerais que chez moi en france les
plus de gilet jaune et plus de problèmes
que tous m'ont dit même et des bords
elle est enterrée ou ton art et un grand
mère basée mondiale ya trois vieilles
qui sont infimes
c'est terrible mémoire je perd la
mémoire je descends chez l'épicier je
dis bonjour monsieur pisser je voudrais
kg 2 1 kg de deux coups de coin vous
souvenez plus [ __ ] de merde et dont tu
fais moi c'est pareil
j'étais dans la cuisine je vais
m'accuser comme ça a été fermé je mets
ma casseroles à une de long et j'allume
part et je laisse les heures comme ça la
troisième je vous plains réussi parce
que moi j'ai une tête comme ça entrée
[Rires]
m